What is load factor, and why do pilots
care about it? What does it mean when a
fighter pilot says that they're pulling
G's, and how could too many G's break
the wings off of my airplane? Those
answers coming up.
Welcome to free pilot training. I'm
Josh, and today we're talking about load
factor. Load factor is an important
topic because it provides two distinct
ways for pilots to kill themselves, and
I'll explain all that. But first, let's
talk about a couple things you need to
know about. When an airplane is in
straight and level flight, the lift that
the wings produce goes straight up. And
once again, we call this vertical lift.
Now, to keep ourselves from descending
during straight and level flight, our
wings only need to produce enough lift
to offset the weight of our aircraft.
That's why I've been emphasizing that in
straight and level flight, lift and
weight are equal. But what happens when
we turn the airplane by rolling it one
way or the other? Well, first, this
causes some of that lift to be pointed
sideways instead of straight up. You
could say that some of this lift is now
moving horizontally, and it's that
horizontal component of lift that causes
our airplane to turn.
But when we roll to the side and we
convert some of that vertical lift to
horizontal lift, vertical lift is
decreased. This means that if we don't
do something, the airplane will descend
because vertical lift and weight are no
longer equal.
So, to keep yourself from descending,
you need to increase the lift that your
wings are producing. And how do you
think we can do that? Yeah, we simply
pull back on the yoke and increase our
angle of attack. And this is what turns
our airplane. It also keeps us from
descending, but when we do this,
something really interesting happens.
How many of you guys remember Newton's
first law of motion from your high
school science class? If you don't, it
basically states that an object in
motion will continue that motion until
acted on by an outside force. In other
words, a moving object is going to have
a tendency to resist changes in its
state of motion. This means that when
you roll an airplane to turn and you
convert your vertical lift to horizontal
lift, the airplane is going to resist
that movement. Now, I'll draw this out
as an arrow moving in the opposite
direction of our horizontal lift, but in
reality, this is just inertia resisting
our change in motion.
And inertia directly opposes the
movement of our aircraft.
So, now you can see that there are two
things that we have to account for if we
want to be able to properly turn the
airplane. We have to overcome inertia to
actually turn the airplane, and then we
have to account for reduced vertical
lift because if we don't, the weight of
the airplane will cause the airplane to
descend. So, weight and inertia are two
forces that combine into a resultant
force that must be overcome in order to
properly turn the airplane.
And this resultant force is what we call
a load or the load factor.
Keep in mind, we also have a resultant
force up here as well. When we combine
our vertical lift and our horizontal
lift, we get what we call total lift.
And ideally, the load should directly
oppose our total lift. Otherwise, the
load could put too much stress on one of
the wings. So, the load factor is a
combination of our weight and the
inertial force that tries to keep our
airplane from turning. And now that you
understand what the load is, we can talk
about some other stuff. First of all,
what part of the airplane is responsible
for holding up the weight of the
aircraft? Yeah, the wings are, aren't
they? And when we roll into a bank,
airplane manufacturers have to account
for that load factor that we place on
the wings. Because if they didn't, the
wings could literally break off anytime
you tried to roll the airplane. And
that's an airplane I'm not interested in
flying. But here's the thing, the load
on your airplane can increase for quite
a few different reasons. And you need to
know what causes that load to increase
so you don't accidentally break off the
wings.
Yes, people have actually broken their
wings off because they didn't understand
this. Now, you already know that when we
roll the airplane, our load increases
when we try to maintain level flight,
but the more you roll the airplane, the
harder it is to maintain level flight
because horizontal lift increases while
vertical lift decreases.
In fact, if you want to maintain level
flight, the load factor has to increase
exponentially with bank angle.
Take a look at this chart. I want you to
notice that the more we increase our
bank angle, the bigger load we need to
keep us from descending.
And at a 90° angle of bank, you cannot
maintain level flight. This is something
you need to keep in mind because if you
bank the airplane too much and you're
trying to maintain a specific altitude,
you can put extreme loads on the
airplane.
Another thing that can increase our load
factor is air speed. This is, once
again, because of Newton's first law.
The faster I'm traveling, the more my
airplane wants to continue moving
straight ahead, and when I bank the
airplane, that inertial force is really,
really strong. So, if I'm super fast and
I roll into a bank, this can also put a
significant load on the wings.
Now, I do want to mention that you don't
necessarily have to be in a turn to
increase the load on the wings.
Let's say I'm in a descent headed
towards the ground. What do you think
will happen if I level out really fast
or I pitched up really aggressively?
Yeah, inertia is going to cause that
weight to put a bigger load on the
wings, won't it? And once again, the
faster we're flying, the bigger the load
factor because the airplane wanted to
continue along its original flight path.
Once again, the wings on our airplane
can only carry so much, and anytime we
increase the load factor, this puts more
of a strain on the wings. And because of
this, we need a way to measure the load
that's put on our aircraft. This is
actually really simple. In fact, we do
this by using gravity as a unit of
measurement. This measurement is what we
call G forces or Gs.
Let's say I weigh 200 lb. If I'm
standing on the ground, I'm pulling 1 G
because the force of gravity is the only
thing keeping me in place.
But if I jumped up and I smacked the
ground, my load factor increases for a
split second. In fact, if I could jump
high enough and I caused myself to weigh
400 lb when I hit the ground, I would be
pulling 2 G's because that's twice the
pull of gravity. If I could jump high
enough to impact the ground with 600 lb
of force, then I would be pulling 3 G's
because my load is three times the force
of gravity.
So, you can see that if I start pulling
4 G's in my Cessna 172 that weighs 2,300
lb, this could really put a strain on
the wings because that would be the same
as my airplane weighing 9,200 lb. That
seems really dangerous, doesn't it?
Yeah, it's extremely dangerous. This is
why aircraft manufacturers will tell you
the load limitations for your aircraft
in the pilot's operating handbook. And
sometimes they'll even put them on a
placard in the airplane so you know for
sure that you're safe.
Take a look at the POH for this Cessna
172 Sierra, and I want you to notice
that we've actually got a few different
G limitations in here.
First of all, we've got two categories
in this plane. We've got a normal and a
utility category.
I'll go into more detail about these in
a future lesson, but these categories
mostly depend on the weight of your
airplane.
Let me ask you a question. Let's say my
mom weighs 160 lb and she jumps up and
smacks the concrete at 2 G's. Would she
cause more or less damage than your mom
if your mom weighs 500 lb and does the
same thing? Well, at 2 G's, your mom is
creating 1,000 lb worth of force, so
just about anything under her is toast
at that point, isn't it? That's why a
lighter aircraft can often take on more
G's, and your airplane is much lighter
in this utility category.
But I want you to notice a couple more
things.
First of all, notice that your wings can
typically take a higher load when the
flaps are retracted. This is because
flaps actually increase the structural
integrity of the wings when they're up.
Then, I want you to notice that we have
a negative G limitation in addition to
the positive G limitation. Have you ever
been on a roller coaster? If so, then
you probably felt all the blood rush to
your head as you started the descent
from that super high spot. This is
basically what a negative G is. Your
weight is actually producing an upward
force instead of a downward force, and I
don't want to spend a bunch of time on
this, but I want you to notice that
airplanes are typically not designed to
take a bunch of negative Gs. This Cessna
172 Sierra can only take -1.52
Gs. So, don't be forcing the nose down
when you're pitched way up unless you're
flying super slow or you're trying to
break a stall. In fact, this is actually
why you're supposed to pitch down before
you roll wings level during the unusual
attitude maneuver.
We want to avoid negative Gs as much as
possible. Now, I do want to mention that
you probably won't break the wings off
of your airplane if you hit your G
limitation. You should never try to fly
an airplane close to its G limits, but
you also don't need to be worried about
breaking your wings off. In reality, if
you were to hit the maximum load of your
airplane, you would definitely damage
the structural integrity of the wing,
and you would possibly bend the metal,
but it actually takes quite a bit to
break the wings off.
But, I want you to consider something.
First of all, how old is the airplane
you're flying? Metal gets weaker with
time. Second, who else has flown this
airplane? If it's been flown by everyone
and their dog, have they damaged the
wings by flying too close to the G
limitations? What happens when you bend
a paper clip one time? It just bends,
doesn't it? But, if I bend it back and
forth, it's going to get brittle, won't
it? Consider that when you're flying.
This is actually what I think happened
to that guy at that gender reveal. I
doubt this is the first time he explored
the G limitations of his airplane. He
probably bent that wing back and forth
and back and forth until the wing
structure was weakened. And then bam,
not a good day. Okay, so that's the
first way that load factor can allow a
pilot to kill himself. In just a minute,
we'll look at another way that you could
kill yourself by accident. But before we
do that, I want to ask you a question.
Are you studying for the private pilot
or the sport pilot written exam? If so,
have you been endorsed to take the
written exam yet? If not, you actually
need an endorsement to take either one
of these tests, and I offer the premium
version of these courses for only $50,
and both of those will issue an
endorsement when you finish them. These
courses take these videos, and they
include over 700 questions worth of
quizzes and practice tests to make sure
you're ready for the FAA written exam.
In addition to reading assignments that
can be super helpful in solidifying
these concepts. And your purchase makes
it possible for me to make these videos,
so please check out
freepilottraining.net if that interests
you. All right, about that, my marketing
manager made me put that in this video.
Anyway, let's talk about another way you
could accidentally kill yourself if you
don't have a good understanding of load
factor. Anytime we increase the load
factor on our airplane, stall speed will
also increase. But don't forget, our
airplane always stalls when the wings
exceed their critical angle of attack,
but the speed at which that happens can
change. And this is important to
remember because if you stall the
airplane at a higher airspeed, you're
probably not going to be expecting it.
And this can be extremely deadly. This
is what we call an accelerated stall.
Take a look at this chart from the
Pilot's Handbook of Aeronautical
Knowledge. Here on the left, we have
load factor, and then on the bottom, we
have speed. And the first thing I want
you to notice on this chart is your
normal stall speed. And I'm showing you
this because I want you to see that up
to this point, the airplane will stall
no matter what the load factor is. But
notice this curve line above our normal
stall speed. As you can see, as load
factor increases, so does stall speed,
just like we mentioned. And actually,
this is something I want to show you
really quick. Stall speed actually
increases by the square root of your
load factor. Keep in mind, you won't
need this for the written exam, but this
is something that you should really know
how to do. Take a look at this chart. As
you can see, in order to maintain level
flight during a 45-degree bank turn, we
have to pull 1.414
G's to keep us from descending. And
because of this, I can actually
calculate the stall speed of my airplane
in a turn, so I know a safe airspeed to
fly so I don't kill myself when I bank
the airplane up to 60°.
And I don't mean to sound crass when I
say this, but extreme bank angles have
killed many pilots for this very reason.
So, it's important for you to know about
this.
Now, I'm not trying to scare you by
showing you this clip. I just want you
to realize that bank angle can
significantly increase the stall speed
of your aircraft. So, let's look at how
much bank angle could actually affect
it. Let's say the stall speed of my
airplane is 50 kn. Once again, stall
speed increases by the square root of
the load factor. So, if I take the
square root of 1.414 G's, this means
that my stall speed will increase by
almost 20%.
This means that my new stall speed will
be almost 60 kn. And once again, if
you're not expecting this, it could be
disastrous.
But, let's take a look back at our
chart. I want you to see something here.
Once again, load factor increases with
stall speed. But, for every airplane,
there's a magical little airspeed that
every pilot should know about. This is
called maneuvering speed or VA.
Up to this airspeed, the airplane will
stall before you could ever possibly
over-G or overload the airplane. If you
fly above this speed, you would bend or
damage the airplane before you could
ever possibly stall.
Keep in mind, there are different
reasons why you might want to fly above
or below this airspeed, but it's
important to know what that airspeed is
in your airplane because this helps you
to make good decisions.
Take a look at the POH in the Cessna 172
Sierra. The first thing you'll notice is
that you typically have more than one
maneuvering speed. And that's because
the speed is based on your weight. Do I
need to remind you about your mom? No,
okay, I won't. But let's say that my
airplane weighs 2,200 lb.
And if I'm flying at an indicated
airspeed of 95 knots, you can see that
VA in this case is 98. So, what should I
be more concerned about if I'm flying at
95 knots? Stalling the airplane or
damaging the airplane?
Yeah, below 98 I'm going to stall first,
won't I? What if I'm flying 105 knots?
Yeah, in this case I'm more concerned
about bending my wings, aren't I?
And this is another reason why airspeed
is so important. In fact, it's so
important that the airspeed indicator is
required anytime you go fly.
And we'll be talking about this more in
an upcoming video. I hope you enjoyed
today's video on load factor. In the
next video, we're going to be talking
about how to calculate load factor. So,
stick around for that video. And by the
way, I want to thank everyone who's
watching this video through one of my
premium ground courses. If you purchased
the $50 course and you're enjoying it,
please comment below and let everyone
know that it was worth the 50 bucks for
this ground course. A lot of people are
hesitant to buy it because it's so
cheap, but if you guys could do that for
me, it would mean a lot. That way they
can see how great of a deal it actually
is. Thanks for doing that and thanks for
watching. We'll see you.